um so this album what would you describe
this album as just in terms of like
the motivation the message yeah you're
at I think it's I think it's just a new
me
um I I took a two-year kind of break
didn't drop a project and before this I
dropped the album every single year
especially as an independent artist of
course you have to do that but I took
like a year two years off and um I kind
of just like did all the bad [ __ ] I had
to do did all the you know did all the
self-reflecting I had to do and just
kind of did everything and I feel like
it's a new me but at the same time it's
just kind of a a just a recap of you
know what I've been through and and
everything yeah what's the uh the the
the the ju I forget the exact date June
what the song on the album The soon six
June 6 what's the significance of that
date
um yeah that's that that's it's a more
of a personal song I try to get real
like in depth and like deep uh about
someone who you know obviously I had a
you know something with but uh I felt
like naming that song not just because
um it's a real uh
I don't know that that day when that was
yeah yeah a bad day or a good day a good
day yeah a good day so I kind of do that
like reflecting on that and when that
day passes by I'm kind of just like you
know I I don't know yeah but you are
pretty outward with your relationships
online I feel like yeah I feel like it's
not
it's not that out of the box it's not
normal people do that but do you always
like you're a famous guy right you
people people [ __ ] [ __ ] bro you're
late I like it man it's lit if I'm with
someone I like to I like to show them
off yeah exactly but is there any like
downside to that because I I mean I'm
not as popping as you but I [ __ ] feel
the downsides well I mean what could be
the downside uh uh NFL players hopping
in the DM I mean
how about this I said I said Tupac was
overrated in an interview once oh [ __ ]
what and I didn't even mean it in like
he's overrated overrated I just meant
he's not top five he's like top ten
maybe you know he's like nine through
ten two yeah he's not top two he's not
um I love and I love Tupac I'm a Tupac
fan yeah but dude there was [ __ ]
these Maniac [ __ ] Tupac fans
who threatened to murder my wife they
dm'd her oh wow yes yeah that'll that'll
get you that see and I didn't even say
it in a disrespectful way yeah
yeah
um so that's social media social media
is crazy social media is crazy but with
me I feel like I'm just I don't I feel
like it's better man to not really have
anything to hide and of course like if
you don't feel like putting your your
business out there it's cool but
if I'm with someone you're comfortable
with it yeah I'm comfortable with it and
yeah and like and like I said whatever
happens happens if someone slides into
the end you know NFL player what and
that that's it for me and you know
if Aaron
Aaron Rodgers
just saying Roger swoops and it was that
easy then it wasn't meant to be in the
first time if Aaron Rodgers DM's my
chick I'm gonna be like go ahead
go ahead you got to leave it up give me
some [ __ ] tickets you got to leave it
up so the girl to the side I need some
good tickets it's all I need go ahead
handle it
let me hang out with him once a year
we'll go do Ayahuasca together like
how's my ex-wife she's good she's a nice
lady right shout out to Aaron Rodgers
that's a different level